-Since the last time you've been
here, I just want to tell you,
you were fantastic
on "Saturday Night Live."
-Thank you.
-You were a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...unbelievable host.
I loved every sketch,
everything you did.
I go -- Man, you crushed it.
-Thanks, man.
That was a dream come true.
-Yeah.
Were you nervous
at all doing it?
-I mean, I would say yes
except you're just too busy.
You get rushed from one thing --
I mean, you know.
I just didn't know.
They're suddenly saying my name
and I'm walking out
and was like,
"Oh, this isn't rehearsal.
We're actually -- This is live.
We're doing it."
-Live television.
Yeah, they don't do live TV
anymore, yeah.
But then they called you back.
-I guess they were gonna do
a "Father of the Bride."
-You were in
"Father of the Bride."
Here you are.
[ Audience awws ]
-Oh! He was once 9.
-That's you.
-Yep.
-And that's Steve Martin.
-Yeah.
-And then so they
did the sketch,
a "Father of the Bride"
kind of reunion
with Martin Short and Steve.
And here you are.
You showed up. It killed.
In the same outfit.
-Yeah.
They did pretty well.
Yeah.
-That's pretty good.
-That's what Matty Banks
would look like
about 30 years in the future.
Yeah, that's right.
-Yeah.
What was it like to reunite
with Marty and Steve?
-That was fantastic.
I didn't think
they were actually gonna
go through with it
when they said, "Are you
available tomorrow to do --"
Tomorrow. It was like
getting the call like,
"Would you show up to 'SNL'
and be Matty Banks?"
Yeah, sure. It'll happen.
-Yeah, why not, though, right?
-It was great.
I always thought
there could be a sequel.
There could be
"Father of the Bride 3"
or just one sketch on "SNL."
Beautifully done.
-When you did
"Father of the Bride,"
"Home Alone" had just come out.
And I'm assuming --
Were you and your brothers
always confused for each other?
-Often, yeah.
It still happens.
I get confused for Rory a lot.
The one that kind of
blew my mind,
when I was about that age, I got
out of a car at an airport,
and a woman ran up to me.
She noticed me right away,
or thought she recognized me
right away,
and ran up and said,
"Are you Macluckly Macluckly?"
[ Laughter ]
And I had the presence of mind
to go, "No, nobody is."
-Yeah, that's not
a human being's name.
-That is not somebody's name.
-Yeah.
-It just isn't.
-But to this day,
do people go up
and they mistake you?
-Often, yeah, like, "You know,
I worked with you on 'Signs.'"
"Oh, yeah, was I a dick?
'Cause that was my brother."
[ Laughter ]
-That's so funny.
-It was Rory.
-That was Rory.
Yeah, of course.
I want to talk
about "Succession"
because, man, you crush it
on this show.
-Oh, thanks.
-This is the beginning...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...of the fourth
and final season.
It starts on Sunday.
Are you gonna miss
playing Roman?
-I think so.
It hasn't hit me,
'cause we only finished
like three weeks ago shooting.
I just have not processed it.
I'm pretty sure, yeah --
what's the thing --
depression, that'll hit.
-Yeah, that will come in soon.
A lot of fans of yours
think that Roman
doesn't understand chairs
and how they work,
because every time
you're sitting,
it's always the oddest position
I've ever seen.
-Yeah.
That's one of the most --
-This is one.
Here's another one.
-Yeah, yeah. Alright.
-And then here's a third one
here of you on top of the --
-Nice face, by the way. Yeah.
-You just don't normally sit
in a chair.
-Yeah, there's a lot
of upside down.
I didn't notice that until
after like the second season
people started
pointing that out.
And a lot of people,
including my wife,
thought that that was, like,
something I was told --
It was either in the writing
or the director said,
"Can you go upside down
on a chair or something?"
-"Can you just like crouch
in the corner on a chair?"
-Yeah, I've been told
that it's weird.
I didn't even notice
I was doing it,
and then I tried to forget
that I heard that
'cause I don't want
to stop sitting weird.
I've already established
that he does that now.
I got to keep it up.
-Yeah, now you got to do it.
I guess, yeah.
Give the people what they want.
Last time we talked,
you came on the show,
I think you were
supposed to audition
for Nicholas Braun's role,
cousin Greg,
but then I heard --
is this true --
that Jeremy Strong
was originally cast to be Roman?
-I think that's when he --
he had picked to be Roman.
That's what I heard.
Like, he was given
the script first
and said he wanted
to play Roman.
I was given it to read
for cousin Greg,
and I didn't feel
I was right for it,
so I just sent in a tape
without asking for Roman, so...
-So Jeremy goes, "I'm gonna --
I don't want to be Roman."
-I don't know. I know that
he wanted to be initially.
But I can't, like, picture it.
I can't picture being Greg
and him being Roman.
What a very odd --
-Yeah.
But it would be odd Roman.
Yeah, you guys are perfect.
The way it is right now
is the perfect cast.
-Yeah.
-And it's --
Dude, everybody is fantastic,
including you.
-Oh, thanks.
-Yeah.
-Including me, wow.
-Yeah, including you.
We can add applause in post.
We have 10 episodes left.
What can we expect
for the final season?
Oh, my goodness.
-Oh, yeah.
You can expect 10 episodes
of the fourth and final season.
I don't know what else to say.
-You really -- Yeah,
you can't spoil anything.
-I can't and I wouldn't want to,
I feel like,
'cause I saw Brian
was on your show
I think yesterday
or the day before.
-He was so funny, by the way.
-He's hilarious.
Like, what the heck.
And, yeah, he said he thinks
that each season got better
than the last,
and I would agree with that.
-He said kind of to me,
he goes --
I go, "Do you think it's gonna
be the final season?"
He goes, "I don't
really feel like --
I think we could've gone more."
'Cause it almost feels like
when a show gets popular,
now is when you get re-upped
for another three seasons
and you go --
-Oh, yeah.
I mean, it could've gone more.
And I feel like --
And the way that we end,
it feels sort of like
there still could be more,
but I think it's also
a satisfying end.
It's nice.
I don't know.
It's like if the options were
go out a high
when there could be more or stay
at the party a little too long,
I'd rather take
the former, so...
-Yeah, yeah, so you left
the party at the right time.
-I guess so.
Well, you never know.
If there was a five,
that could've been great.
I'm saying, Jesse,
write a fifth season.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
It's so good.
It's so clever.
It's so well-acted.
It's so funny.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kieran Culkin
in "Succession."
Take a look.
-So my question was, uh, would
you consider giving him a call?
-Would we consider
at least a call?
-Uh...was he apologizing?
-Did -- I mean, did he ask?
-Um, did he ask?
-Uh, he -- I just --
I know that he would love
to hear from you.
-I mean, if he were to call,
then we would see.
-Yeah, I think it's just gonna
be a lot to get him to call,
just knowing him.
-Yeah, I mean, I think we know
him pretty well, actually.
I mean, we've never licked
his big omelet nipples, but --
-I could get him to text
a request for a call.
-Text?
I'm afraid we're gonna need
to hear that voice.
Okay, you can pop it back
in your mouth now.
We're getting on the plane.
Thanks. Bye.
-Come on.
Kieran Culkin, everybody.
The fourth and final season
of "Succession"
premieres on HBO this Sunday.